[Music]
do you have an application with global
reach one with millions or even billions
of users who need highly accurate
real-time information the database that
sits behind your application empowers
your users can dictate your users
experience your ability to grow and your
global resilience
cloud spanner is a strongly consistent
highly scalable relational database that
is fully managed by google cloud so how
is cloud spin are so powerful
well it creates multiple copies or
replicas of your data and stores these
replicas across geographical locations
for enterprises with globally
distributed users a multi-region
configuration is ideal as it protects
against regional failures enables you to
scale to new places and provides faster
reads by having a copy of your database
near your users let's unpack how it
works for multi-region configurations
cloud spanner creates five replicas of
your data and distributes them across
three regions
one region is the leader region which is
responsible for handling rights
the leader logs the right and sends it
to other replicas any right to the
database requires a quorum or agreement
between at least two regions
this ensures that if a region fails
there are at least two regions that can
form a quorum with full up-to-date
copies of your data so your database can
continue to be available without any
data loss so what happens if the leader
region fails
cloud spanner is built to be resilient
and moves the leader to another region
the new leader region and the other
available region form the quorum this
means the database continues to be
available your application might see
slightly higher latencies during the
later movement but won't experience any
downtime to scale your application
across the world you can use read-only
regions close to your users reads and
cloud spanner will by default read the
latest data these are called strong
reads and are served by a replica
closest to the user
if the read is in a different region
from the leader the replica may have to
communicate with the leader to know
whether it has the latest data and this
can increase latency to get faster reads
you can use stale reads stale reads are
done at a time stamp in the past
for example 15 seconds in the past and
are useful if you can tolerate slightly
older data businesses around the world
are powering their users with cloud
spanner
a multi-region configuration gives you
the peace of mind that you have high
availability low latency and resilience
against regional failures
to find out more check out the cloud
spanner website
[Music]
you